hi I'm Devin de Kapadia I work at
Wolfram and the manager for calculus and
algebra and this off no no I speak with
it I say yeah and 5 p.m. about
streamlining mathematical education and
talk about linear algebra initiatives
that will take bring the mix here I meet
I say yeah if I'm a senior criminal
developer I'll be presenting some stuff
with my colleague Devendra here by
itself each one of these things is sort
of small and not super impressive but
actually I became increasingly convinced
as I prepared this talk and so I hope
you will also be convinced that together
that they make a nice collection of
enhancements so I'm going to be talking
about the various enhancements we've
made to just make Mathematica a little
bit more friendly particularly for
students but also for anybody who uses
it and there will be sort of three areas
sort of dedicated functions for certain
tasks enhance presentation of existing
results and improve documentation so I'm
going to start with enhanced
presentation so here's a nice cubic
equation you might want to solve and I'm
using a trick here to solve it in eleven
three and it goes at things deep
thoughts and it returns root of blah
which first of all is not very
informative and if even if it were you
know I can read that I'm like oh it gave
me the the polynomial back is a pure
function and it says it has five roots
yay because I didn't know the
fundamental theorem of algebra so now if
you do this in version 12 you'll see
something like that well that looks much
nicer so we have one root that is about
minus one point eight three and if I
hover over it it's a little hard to see
on that screen but if I hover over it
then there's a tooltip with the old
input form if you want to know those
details then we have
conjugate pair and the second conjugate
pair which we had to have pairs since
all real coefficients now these look
very different but they're in fact the
exact same expression if I take the old
result and stick it into new kernel then
I see something that looks like the new
result here
conversely if I take this new looking
result and stick it into an old Colonel
it evaluates to what it gave so this is
purely a change in formatting not a
change in what's actually returned it's
what we in the biz call typesetting so
some more examples here's solving
something with fractional powers and you
get a power of a root object now again
you get the same root of the newly
formatted six root object raised to the
sixth power you could when you were
solving transcendental equations you
could get really scary looking things
like this root object here with 20 or 40
however many digit numbers in it now
again it's the same result but you see
something that's actually somewhat
informative you hover over it you can
see all the gory details if you want to
and here we have returning a conditional
expression o to disk I lose our T's out
of order they're just out of order right
so here we have a root inside of a
conditional expression because we're
solving trig equations so we have a plus
two pi I and there's our root new root
object as opposed to trying to figure
out what we're looking at here it's very
clear here because it's so compact what
we're looking at okay couple details the
new formatting is not used when there
are some both parameters because well
there isn't a number we can stick into
little blob so that will require further
option the new roots will evaluate so if
you save a notebook and send it to
somebody running 11 3 it will evaluate
those roots will continue to work
however they will not look very pretty
so it's important for you to for them to
look something that doesn't look like
it's a damaged notebook then there's the
system option right here you can
temporarily turn off the new format or
permanently if you hate it for some
reason
turn off the new formatting and use the
old formatting so that's route another
guy which got some enhanced presentation
is C so C is our undetermined constant
that comes up in these solve and other
places and so we have C of one C of two
and so forth well now it looks like
something a little bit more familiar
their subscripts rather than function
application again it's still the same
expression it just is formatted
differently and most important
differential equation because basically
every physical system is just this
equation and disguise that was a joke
for the physicists out there but again
we get now pretty formatting C one
cosine of X C 2 sine of X the
traditional form is unchanged it already
we use subscripts so but this is so this
half of the slide is just changing
presentation but we now have C in lots
of new places so for example by popular
demand we have it and integrate so if
you want the plus C generous they
generated parameters goes to C and voila
you get a plus C sometimes constants
aren't so constant so in this example
we're integrating first with respect to
X and second with respect to Y and I
just set that backwards but you know
what I mean and we could see one of Y
and see 2 of X because if you different
if you take the mixed partial X Y then
this terminal file and that term will
fall out in addition we have this in
discrete integrals also known as sum
and also in products they've worked very
much the same way if you want more
details on things and similar things go
TV what's new in calculus and algebra
talk which is tomorrow morning at 10:30
okay
so switching to sort of dedicated
functions we have a bunch of new number
domains in 12 basically we have signed
versions of the reals rationals and
integers there are different standards
for how to format these things we pick
the one which is very unambiguous so the
positive reals is are greater than zero
the are greater than non-negative reals
is are greater than or equal to zero
there's no question about is the plus
strict or not strict it's just very very
clear so these very much behave like you
might expect so if you ask if pie is a
member of any of these domains well it's
a not it's a positive real it's a
non-negative real but it's not a
negative real nor is it any kind of
rational number similarly minus 1/2 is a
negative rational and even a non
positive rational but it's not an
integer and zero as you might expect is
in the non versions but not in the
strict versions and you can use this in
lots of places for example
simplification so is e to the X a
positive real when X is an element of a
true reals
yes it is and if X is less than is if X
is in the negative reals is e to the X
between 0 and 1 and again that's true
and here's one with integers so I'm
asking as ABS of n equal to 4 of n and
if N is a positive integer that is true
if n is whoops
if n is a negative integer then that's
false
okay so now
oh yeah yes thank you for asking me
Brett
we have keyboard shortcuts for all of
these they are the the same
abbreviations we used for real rationals
and then teachers only you put in either
a P and n a PN or sorry an NP or an N n
so then and whoops escape and and reels
or we have reels and rats for the
rationals or NP I for the non and again
that because of how floating cells work
that's kind of hard to see up there but
it says NP ants therefore the non
positive integers and voila okay so
these are sort of formatting and sort of
elementary things the next few slides
are also sort of elementary math but
that's actually not as trivial
functionality as you might think so
common questions you would get are like
how do I add 5 to both sides of an
equation or how do I add the respective
sides of these equations so the answer
all the answer used to be used thread or
use replace or map or something else
didn't you answer as much simpler use
dedicated functions so if you want to
add 5 to both sides of the equation say
add sites to x equals y 5 and voila or
if you want to add the respective sides
you can give it a couple of equations or
and you're not limited to two sides you
can have three sides as long as you have
the same number of sides then subtract
sites is analogous and okay it's still
ok on time
only it also has a one argument form
which is move everything to the left
well to the leftmost side and right and
just for comparison here are
what you used to have to do so adding a
constant was really not too bad at least
if you are comfortable with map or the
pattern manager although you know most
calculus students are not and for adding
respective equations again with thread
if you understand it it's not too bad
but trying to do it with any other way
this was the only other sort of you know
what would be the map like way to do it
this was the easiest way I came up with
which is really not very easy I didn't
have one student who once he learned
about triple at he tried to use it for
everything including things he really
shouldn't have but you know that's not a
very common not a very common occurrence
of course you know equations are super
simple what about inequalities well
those are handled or you can add an
equation and inequality and it'll
correctly figure out what the correct
inequality to put in or if you have in
equations
more than two sides it also knows about
piecewise so if you give it a piecewise
function it will sorry piecewise
relation it'll go in and find the
relations and add things and it also
knows about conditional expression which
is very important as you will see on the
next slide so adding and subtracting is
actually pretty simple then there's a
multiplication and division which at
first starts out pretty analogously you
have multiply sides and it looks
basically just like add sides then you
have divide sides and it starts out
looking okay but then you divide two
equations and you get a piecewise thing
out or if you do divide sides on the
single equation you get an equation out
and so we have this option generate
conditions and the defaults to all which
is a special value for multiplied to
fight sides which means if it needs a
condition it's going to give you all
possible results as a piecewise
expression now there are various other
settings which are specific to sorry
which are general which are shared with
all the other functions we've been
recently working on and adding generate
conditions to you so for example general
conditions because the true means pick
one true result give it to me
and tell me what condition you use to
get there so here it shows the positive
side and voila with false it will still
figure out a correct answer but it won't
tell you which condition it shows and
then there's none which means if you
need to generate the condition then
don't do anything just come back as is
generate conditions goes to automatic is
tries to be a little bit clever so if
you need a quote unquote non-generic
result a something which is true is a
condition I guess not a generic result
is easier to define a generic result
there's one that's true except that
single points isolated single isolated
points then don't give those but if you
need a non-generic condition then give
it otherwise so here so for this
condition automatic and true behave the
same way but for this condition where
you just need to exclude be equal to 0
then automatic doesn't give the
condition true gives the condition and
since I don't think I have quite enough
time I have some bonus details here on
exactly when conditions are generated
and the exact relationship between the
result and the inputs if you want to
know some real if you want to realize
just how complicated basic algebra is
it's worth a look but in the interest of
time I will skip over that so finally we
have apply sides
which applies a general function to an
equation so you can exponentiate both
sides or take the square root of both
sides and it understands all the same
things the one way it's very very
different is it's a really a structural
operation it's not going to verify that
what it gives to you is still
mathematically equivalent because that's
really really really hard slash
impossible so for example here it took
the sine of both sides but that's
obviously not this equivalent sign of a
greater than sign of B is not equivalent
to a greater than B so one example which
I blatantly stole from the documentation
but it's okay because I wrote the
documentation is deriving the quadratic
formula using these new functions so you
start out with a quadratic equation you
multiply both sides by 4a
you add b squared minus 4ac to both
sides you factor the left-hand side you
take the positive square root of both
sides which we do by first taking the
square root and then applying power
expand then you subtract B from both
sides and finally you divide both sides
assuming a is not zero which is okay
because it's a quadratic equation if a
were zero you would not have started out
with a quadratic equation and voila X is
minus B plus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac over 2a thank you
sorry okay so the last area and I'll
talk briefly about this is we've been
slowly updating the documentation for
our functions our examples a lot of them
are now is inspired by actual textbooks
I mean we had a group of interns who
solved every problem in Stuart using
Mathematica we also looked at Martha
Marsden and Tron before the vector
calculus Holli
so on and so forth and so these are
we're already introduced sort of version
or two back if you look at them then
sort of we have sort of pretty pictures
explaining what exactly the function is
doing we have tables with different you
know different ways of entering things
and especially if you look at the
application sections then you have you
know relation to integration you have
rates of change or with you know rates
of change to type problems l'hopital's
rule oh you know where where did all the
areas go they skip relations integration
multivariate it's a change if you like
they're examples missing from Kenya are
we having a build problem but anyway
lots of examples then similarly limit
which we updated in eleven two with lots
of new functionality again in the
interests of time I'm going to skip over
all the many wonderful changes we made
although I will just mention limits are
two-sided by default now that's very
useful for calculus students and again
we have lots of details with you know
different ways of entering things
pictures of what these things mean and
so on and so forth so that's integrate
again in the interest of time I won't
show you but that's what we've been
doing calculus and our next point is
linear algebra so I'll let the vendrá
take over right now hello hello thank
you
I just want to spend a couple of minutes
on something I've been thinking quite
deeply over the last one year so it I
spoke about algebra middle school high
school algebra the next step is linear
algebra and I mean think really deeply
about this so the point is that linear
algebra very simply the study of linear
equations and today linear algebra is
really the most important requirement
you need to fulfill for many things like
you know engineering data science of
course you need calculus but linear
algebra really rules this world of
applied mathematics and we did a survey
last two he found that linear algebra
and differential equations and thing
there are really very very popular
courses so he said let's try and
understand this is kind of market of
linear algebra textbook etc now when I
was turned to read study books by Hal
Moss and Hoffman Kunze so if you could
solve often and Kunze completely you
could pass the PhD prelims but we are
not allowed to ask what's the
application of linear algebra he just
studied it and that was it I did a one
book which was my Finkbeiner and that
did a bit more in the chapter on linear
programming that was concession and you
had to hide it because no one would let
you do application you know so that's
the way life was a long time ago but
things have changed now and so last year
I just said they were in the by the top
six textbook so linear algebra and study
them and pick one well I studied six of
them and the two finalists were Gilbert
Strang linear algebra and David Lee
training of course at MIT so MIT is a
good name to have and of course he's a
fantastic teacher but I finally settled
on David leis book on linear algebra
because it had 4 and 67 Amazon reviews
and wonderful applications etc so I then
hired two interns over the summer so
last some of you we finished Stewart
6000 examples in this sum I said told
them look you're a solid full book
through the summer so he sat down
and prepared this solution manual for
linear algebra every problem in lays
solved over here and that's the table of
contents so let me just enlarge the
tributary if I can and if you click on
any one of these so let's say click over
here application to computer graphics
that's the section computer graphics
with every example typed in questions
answered everything nothing left out and
it's quite nice to see how the Wolfram
language copes or doesn't cope in some
cases with what's we done over here so
that's the letter n you sheer it a
little bit and what happens it goes
there how do you do that kind of thing
so we now have a complete solution
manual for one of the most popular
textbooks in linear algebra and from
Euron will update reference pages for
linear algebra inverse determined etc
which are not in well compared with
calculus punch they're on good shape and
then hopefully next year we might even
have a linear algebra course like the
one I did for calculus this year so I'm
gearing up to building linear algebra as
a major direction for our team so
tomorrow Thursday we have a meet-up on
algebra from 1to and ETA is organizing
that so if you are a teacher student
parent whatever
believe me linear algebra is important
I'd like to believe that very advanced
mathematics is important to know it's
linear algebra their crews in the world
okay
I wish Speedy's were more important but
I don't think most people understand him
so the truth is linear algebra is
important we would like to hear what you
have to say so if you're interested and
if you have some time do come along to
be very informal from one to two in
Homewood and I stopped oh yeah thank you